Now for the answer. Let's check all that apply.
A simplified test case is easier to communicate.
This is correct, because if it's simpler, takes less time, easier to understand.
A simplified test case usually means small fixes.
Unfortunately, that's not the case.
It may mean faster fixes, but it does not mean smaller fixes.
The fix will be the same whether the test case is in its original complex form or whether it's simplified.
A simplified test case usually means smaller program states. Yes.
If the input is smaller, then all the data structures that represent the input will be smaller as well.
And, a simplified test case usually means fewer program steps.
This is correct as well, because it takes fewer steps to process the simplified input.
And there we go.